revista de prensa en directo América por
ello le doy la bienvenida a mi compañera
Marta Moya Marta muy buenos días Hola
Andrés Buenos días Marta vamos a abrir
la revista de prensa en Estados Unidos
porque cada vez los rumores son más
fuertes entre Florida y Washington Y es
que el Gobernador rondes antes parece
que podría anunciar su candidatura
republicana la próxima semana una
contienda directa Entre él y el
expresidente Donald Trump veamos cómo lo
reflejan medios como CNN por ejemplo
Pues sí Andrés vamos a hablar de CNN que
ayer reportaba que Fuentes del partido
republicano concretamente dos Fuentes
cercanas a ron de santis anunciaron que
el Gobernador de Florida tendría ya todo
hilado para presentar su candidatura
como precandidato republicano para las
elecciones de 2024 elecciones que
tendrán lugar en noviembre del próximo
año y las que parece que va a haber una
pugna otra vez entre
Trump o biden también no está en esta
carrera
este artículo de la CNN que ron de
santis va a presentar la documentación
que lo declara como candidato ante la
comisión federal electoral y lo
acompañará de un breve acto sin embargo
el acto oficial de su candidatura No se
podría o sea podría darse no esta semana
que viene sino la siguiente en su ciudad
natal en Florida en dandyl y bueno otras
fuentes de el partido republicano
sostienen que todo este esquema podría
variar porque ronde santis acostumbra a
sorprender a sus asesores con
movimientos de última hora de ser así
Eso sí como decimos Pues ya sería
oficialmente esta pugna contra el
expresidente Donald Trump por ver quién
se convierte en candidato republicano a
la casa blanca Así es vamos entonces a
ver lo que dice el New York Times por
ejemplo pues Andrés el New York Times
refleja una llamada telefónica que hizo
ayer de santis con sus principales
donantes en la que dijo que solo habría
tres candidatos creíbles para las
elecciones de 2024 Jo Donald Trump Y él
sin embargo que solo él tenía las
capacidades para primero ganar Las
primarias y después ganar Las
presidenciales contra hipotéticamente
biden recordemos que para empezar a
pedir donaciones primero un candidato
tiene que presentar oficialmente su
candidatura y esto se va a dar antes del
25 de mayo donde hay prevista una gran
reunión para recaudar fondos de hecho ya
ha habido
reservas de 100 habitaciones de hotel en
un lujo complejo hotelero donde pues se
va a haber recepciones de donantes y
sesiones informativas la próxima semana
en Miami esta llamada pues estuvo
plagada también de dardos contra el
expresidente Donald Trump dijo
textualmente de santis que hay algunos
candidatos que recaudan dinero para
ellos mismos dijo que Trump se había
centrado durante su mandato en el plano
ejecutivo dejando de lado el congreso
que no había desarrollado una reducción
del gasto y que el objetivo de los
republicanos sacar a biden pero que él
solo tenía las herramientas para hacerlo
y que Donald Trump no por todos los
escándalos que envuelven al expresidente
no obstante Donald Trump Pues sigue
aventajando a ron de santis en más de 30
puntos en las encuestas nacionales Así
es aún los dos siguen siendo nombres que
suenan muy fuerte de Cara a la
candidatura republicana Marta de
casualidad casualidad o no la revista
Time dedica esta semana su portada
también a este mismo personaje ron de
santis Pues sí Andrés vemos en esta
portada de la revista Time una
ilustración de ron de santis con las
banderas de Estados Unidos y de Florida
y él sale pelando una naranja en lo que
podría ser una alusión directa al
expresidente Donald Trump el Time titula
esta portada lo que ronde Santi
significa para Estados Unidos
Marta pero el Time no solo se queda en
la portada sino que también le dedica un
amplio reportaje en el interior de sus
páginas que dice Pues sí Andrés un
extensísimo de verdad reportaje que
titula el proyecto de santis desgrana en
este informe Cuáles han sido los puntos
clave de la política de el actual
gobernador de Florida también habla de
su vida personal ronde santis 44 años ex
jugador de béisbol estudió derecho y se
alistó después en la Marina en bajo este
rol participó en la guerra de Irak a
partir de 2010 según este artículo del
Time de santis empieza a tener
aspiraciones políticas primero en los
estamentos locales después pasa a ser
congresista por un periodo de tres
mandatos y luego ya pues gobernador de
Florida por dos legislaturas
consecutivas recordemos que en noviembre
de 2022 ganó frente a su contendiente
demócrata por Más de 19 puntos destaca
también un poco el carácter personal y
político de santis textualmente dice el
time lo que quiere el gobernador lo
obtiene el gobernador de santis es quien
dio la bienvenida a esta pelea de santis
es quien Toma las decisiones y de santis
quien obtendrá el rédito o la culpa de
sus movimientos en un Frenesí de
políticas de derecha recordemos que los
últimos meses ha prohibido el aborto a
partir de las sexta semana del embarazo
ha prohibido hablar de cuestiones de
género sexuales en las escuelas a
menores de edad ha prohibido el
tratamiento a menores trans y que estos
participen en eventos deportivos en las
escuelas las restricción de servicios
básicos para personas indocumentadas o
el libreporte de armas ahora rondesandis
quiere exportar esta política Florida de
Florida a nivel Estatal hay que ver pues
si le van a dar los números para hacerse
con esta candidatura republicana Andrés
sobre todo esta puja que mantiene con
Disney alrededor del control por los por
este territorio que administra este gran
complejo de entretenimiento Marta vamos
a cerrar hoy con un récord mundial
porque esta semana se anunció que un
personaje recorrió siete maravillas del
mundo moderno en menos de una semana
Cómo es eso un hito De verdad nos
referimos al youtuber británico
aventurero es Jamie McDonald que anunció
recientemente haber roto este récord
mundial visitando las siete maravillas
del mundo concretamente en seis días 16
horas y 14 minutos desde la Gran Muralla
China hasta el Taj Mahal en India Petra
en Jordania al Coliseo de Roma el Cristo
Redentor en Río de Janeiro Machu Picchu
en Perú o Chichén Itzá en México cuatro
continentes nueve países 13 vuelos 16
taxis 9 buses 4 trenes y 37.000
kilómetros según ha confirmado el
guinness record todo esto financiado por
una empresa de reserva de viajes y él
asegura que todo lo recaudado por este
récord guinness irá destinado a su
fundación benéfica supergiro para ayudar
a personas que necesitan tratamientos
médicos y no tienen los recursos para
ello y uno se pregunta cómo hace Porque
si uno va a una de estos países
usualmente le toma un día en visitar un
monumento de estos por el acceso agotado
Eso sí obviamente Marta Muchas gracias
por la revista de prensa nos vemos
mañana entonces nos vemos la próxima
semana la próxima semana en una nueva